G: Okay...
G: Hey guys. My name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now! I'm here with Kristen!
K: Hi!
G: We did a video just now on her channel, that you guys should go watch after this.
K: Yes
G: We made prison food.
K: I don't feel good.
G: I mean I would say that's why I'm dressed this way, but honestly...
K: You'd wear that...
G: ... normally.
G: I thought Kristen would be really fun to talk through the MTV EMA's...
K: Yeah...
G: European Music Awards?
G: I'm assuming is what that stands for.
K: That makes sense.
G: Sure.
K: I didn't know this was a thing until now.
G: I didn't know it was a thing until I saw it on Twitter.
G: I don't know music. So we are going to review -this happened over the weekend- some of the red carpet fashions from
the EMA's.
G: First we have...
Camila Cabello.
K: Work...
G: Is that that how you say her name?
K: Camila ke-ba-ya?
G: The girl that left fifth harmony. I mean...
K: Hold on.
G: There's a lot- there's a lot of beautiful saran-wrap seemingly happening in this photo.
G: She's got a corset, but it also looks like you know those bras that you wear that are just sticky bras?
G: And she's got straight-up what looks like a plastic bag wrapped around her neck.
K: Honestly at the top...
G: Yes.
K: It looks like where you tie the bag when you're taking it out to the trash.
G: The bottom half looks a little bit like grandmother's nightie,
G: but she also does look like a porcelain doll so...
K: True.
G: Kudos. But this part just makes me feel anxious that she's suffocating.
K: That's exactly what I was thinking, because I look at it as a plastic bag too, so I'm like-
K: She's got a plastic bag around her neck. We all learn not to do that.
G: Yeah *laughing* that's what they teach you... plastic bags are
for putting anything in but your head.
G: Demi Lovato!
K: Oh!
G: Whoah!
K: Oh my god.
G: She looks...
K: ... so good.
G: ...super badass. She looks like Demi Moore so much here.
K: Yeah.
G: She's a- got the long black hair.
K: Yeah yeah.
G: And her body and skin looks photoshopped
G: But she also looks like, the sexiest like, Nantucket businessman I've ever seen.
K: How can you make that sexy?
G: We'd have to DM her to find out.
K: True. I'Il give her that. I'll give her that. I always fear-
K: open things like that because it's...it's stuck with fashion tape. Like if you sweat too much you're screwed.
G: If you hug the wrong way,
G: if the wind blows too hard...
G: I like when girls wear masculine clothing-
K: Yes, me too.
G: -and make it like really sexy.
G: And she really is. She always looks so angry fierce.
G: But good thing that she's probably wearing really expensive shoes that we can't see.
K: If she were wearing Crocs and it'd be fine.
G: That would be hilarious.
K: Financially responsible.
G: Right? *laughing*
G: Next we have Rita Ora!
K: Stop!
G: She hosted the EMA's...
K: Okay.
G: And I'm kind of obsessed with this whole look.
G: She showed up like she just got out of the most elegant shower of all time.
K: Oh my gosh.
G: But she's wearing these insane jewels. I think she was like running late and was like I don't give a sh*t! I'm Rita Ora.
G: I'm hosting the event this is what we're doing, and I kind of love this so much.
K: That's where I aspire to be.
G: Sexy-
K: It looks good though!
G: I know! That's the confusing thing, it's like, how is she wearing just a towel on her head
G: and she looks so sexy? This feels like this would be the most amazing like Marriott commercial of all time.
K: She's so comfy. Wow!
G: She's great. Good for her. She's changed the game.
K: I'm inspired
G: Now I have Shawn Mendes!
K: Oh my God, he looks so old.
G: I know, this is when you watch sitcoms and the first season there's like a little boy on there and by the fourth season
G: it's uncomfortable to watch him because he's... you're watching him go through puberty.
K: And he's one of those people that use... their age never changes.
G: Right, that he's in the blurry zone that you're like I'm not gonna even like think about him-
K: No.
G: -because that's not a person that I should be wondering what the age is of them. K: But...
K: this is cool though. The prints...
G: Yeah.
K: I'm digging it. It's fun and distracting.
G: Yes. I think this is cool,
G: cause he is a musician, but he looks like he could be like a boring white boy.
G: You would look at him and say that's like an Abercrombie and Fitch model. That person's not gonna be interesting,
G: and then you find out that he's super musically talented.
K: True.
G: This is giving him that cool music image.
K: It's like humble... it's like Susan Boyle.
*record scratch*
*laughing*
G: Some might say Shawn Mendes is the Susan Boyle of young up-and-coming male musicians.
G: He's doing a stylish look without being like over the top and it still seems subtle weirdly enough.
G: Now we have Haley Baldwin.
K: I... I thought that was Gigi Hadid. I don't know people.
G: She's friends with Gigi and all those girls.
K: Fair that I got it mixed up then.
G: Yes.
G: She's at like every young person award show event and she always looks sad.
K: Oh, she does looks sad.
G: She always looks like her dad told her she can't go to prom.
K: Wait is this the one that's dating... no that's....ungh....no...
G: Are you having a stroke?
K: Yeah... *laughing*
K: Zayn from One Direction?
G: No, that's Gigi Hadid.
K: Okay, see.
G: I like this dress.
K: It's slippery.
G: Yeah, she looks like she's got oil poured all over her, which is cute.
K: Those shoes are cool.
G: They're like choking your ankles. Chokers for your ankles. Cute!
G: This is Jared Leto.
K: It's like Dora the Explorer in a sweatsuit.
G: It looks like Borat met Dora the Explorer
G: and this is the final outcome. And also I think he's wearing what could be orthopaedic shoes,
G: but I think they're the new Kanye West sneaker. It's very much like 80s prom date on the top and then like retired...
G: Italian man on the bottom.
K: Wow!
G: That's I mean... it's a look. It's a combo.
K: A look
G: Yeah, but I don't hate it.
G: Okay. This is Lana Del Rey.
K: Oh! I really like that dress though. That's really cool. It screams...
...
K: Gardening.
G: Yeah. *laughing*
K: She always just looks like she doesn't talk.
G: But I think this dress is really cool and fun and still appropriate.
K: Yes. It's so loud, but it's somehow still very like...
G: compared to Rita Ora...
*laughing*
G: Okay, this is Liam Payne.
K: That's a normal outfit!
G: Uh...
K: It's fine. G: It...
G: ...yeah. He looks uncomfortable .
K: He's probably sweating. G: Yeah,
G: he looks like both of his arms are paralyzed,
K: Yes.
G: or that he just came from like skiing?
G: But then also a funeral before that.
K: He looks like constipated like it's like...
K: I sharted.
G: Uh, the orange is fine, but I don't know to me it just seems like a little disconnected.
G: Did I just give an opinion about orange right now? *laughing*
G: This is Charli XCX.
K: I didn't... I never had a face to that name.
G: Me neither.
K: It's comfy.
G: I mean this could be the same outfit that Liam Payne is wearing under that shirt.
K: Oh my... *laughing*
G: We just don't know
G: Cute couples costume. Like a sexy mime happening right now.
K: Yes.
G: It's like crop top painting teacher.
K: Painting teacher? *laughing* Art Teacher?
G: Yeah! Otherwise known as an art teacher maybe?
G: Okay, this is Madison Beer.
G: This... is... a look.
K: I can't stop looking at her boobs.
G: I know... her boobs are pushed so high!
K: And do the straps say something?
G: I can't tell but it's just making me look more at her boobs.
K: I think it says "Christian".
G: Oh.
G: Is she a Christian? Is that the messaging? But it's like right next to her tits? Like right up there.
K: Oh!
G: I'm sure it's probably Christian Dior,
and I'm secretly hoping she's just letting everyone know that she's a Christian and it's directly next to her tits.
K: Eyes here, now look at my religion.
G: Yeah! *laughing* My religion is down here. How dare you.
G: Uh yeah, this is Travis Scott.
K: Cool jacket!
G: Yeah, I can't tell what's on the jacket.
G: It's like a jack-in-the-box,
G: but like a ghoul is coming out of it.
K: The pants look like the pants that you unzip at the knees.
G: Yeah, they look like the pants that the kid that played D&D in high school wore.
Diane: I think that Travis Scott is Kylie Jenner's rumoured baby Daddy.
G: *gasp* K: Oh!
G: Well, he looks like he just put a baby in someone.
K: The rumors are confirmed!
G: There you go, you heard it here first. This is what dads are wearing in 2017.
G: This is Julia Michaels.
K: She's cool looking.
G: This is a confusing look because it's like one pant leg and then a skirt wrapped around the other one which seems like it would be very
G: uncomfortable and jarring to wear.
G: I have pants on but no, I don't.
G: I also have my cooter hanging out and...
K: Cooter! This looks... not breathable, but chic.
G: But very chic.
G: And she also looks like the kind of girl that like I want that girl to be my friend.
G: She looks like a badass that would like really tear someone down if they f**ked with me.
K: But then I feel like you talk to her and she's so nice.
G: Yeah, but she looks unapproachable, and then she's just like so sweet.
K: Now we're just judging her personality and not her clothes.
G: And not her clothes at all.
G: Okay, so this is the last one: Kesha!
K: Oh!
K: This is screams Tik Tok.
G: Yeah!
K: It screams like old, Kesha.
G: Yeah, which I really like. It's a weird
G: space galaxy unicorn cowboy look.
K: Space cowboy!
G: She's got space cowboy vibes.
*music* "Take the space vibe with the cowboy, baby"
K: It's like mermaid space cowboy.
G: Yeah!
G: It's like your aunt that lives in Texas like went off the grid and did a bunch of LSD and then came back
G: and was like, this is who I am now.
K: Literally. It's all her normal clothes, but just shiny
G: Yeah. *laughing*
G: She just added sequins to all of her normal clothes.
K: I get it... I get life now.
G: Well there we go!
K: Wow...
G: That was our review of the EMAs.
G: Overall I think... goods and bads.
K: Everybody expressed themselves and that's all that matters.
G: Truly...
G: I can't really say anything negative about any of it because they've all put much more effort and time and thought into their looks than
G: clearly I ever do...so...
K: And... they're there and we're not.
G: That's true.
K: They're invited to these things and were sitting back just judging them because we're jealous.
G: If you guys want to feel
G: not so jealous of us eating delicious meals go over to Kristen's Channel
G: and watch the video where we tried to make prison foods.
K: It was interesting and I learned a lot about myself.
G: We both should probably head to our respective homes to use the restrooms at some point in the soon future.
K: Yes.
G: Thank you guys so much for watching! Other than that, I don't know.
G: Okay, this is... I forget this girl's name. Oh yeah, Sabrina! Sabrina Carpenter.
K: Okay.
G: Who apparently is a big musician... I don't know.
K: She has a cute butt!
G: Yeah, that's great. Moving on...